- That said, you popularized
the asymptotic notation,
for describing running time.
Obviously in the analysis of algorithms.
Worst cases, such an important part.
Do you see any aspects of that
kind of analysis as lacking?
And notation too?
- Well, the main purpose,
we should have notations that help us,
for the problems we wanna solve.
And so--
- Right.
- They match our intuitions.
And the people who worked in number theory
had used asymptotic
notation in a certain way,
but it was only known to
a small group of people,
and I realized that, in fact,
it was very useful to be able to
have a notation for something
that we don't know, exactly, what it is,
but we only know partial, about it.
For example, instead of big-O notation,
let's just take a much simpler notation,
where I say, zero or one?
Or zero one or two?
And suppose that, when I
had been in high school,
we would be allowed to put
in the middle of our formula,
X plus 01R2 equals Y, okay?
And then we would learn how to multiply
two such expressions together,
and I'd deal with them.
Well the same thing, big-O notation says,
here's something that,
I'm not sure what it is
but I know it's not too big.
I know it's not bigger than
some constant times N squared,
or something like that.
- Right.
- And so I write
big-O of N squared.
Now I learn how to add big-O of N squared
to big-O of N cubed,
and I know how to add big-O of N squared
to plus one and square that,
and how to take logarithms
and exponentials
who have big-Os in the middle of them.
And that turned out to be hugely valuable,
in all of the work that I was tryin' to do
as I'm tryin' to figure out
how good an algorithm it...